here's why saying no is so much more
important than saying yes in making
money building relationship building the
life that you want life is really long
but it takes time to build big things
and so you might only have four or five
big entrepreneurial seasons of five to
ten years in you so if you imagine you
had five bullets that you could shoot
and you have a billion potential
opportunities and every one of those
targets comes to you and says shoot at
me shoot at me shoot at me your ability
to say no over and over and over again
and take your one shot on the one time
that matters is the hardest discipline
that will get you the highest return it
is the skill that must be learned first
otherwise you get deluded and you never
make progress towards the one or two big
opportunities that you really should
pursue in your life